now 6 21 it's a monday morning and it's
time to say good morning to monica
jackson monica good morning to you how
was your weekend oh it was great how was
yours it was good got a chance to get
outside and it was a beautiful weekend
across everywhere i think let me tell
you you know what when you live in las
vegas you really can't complain about
anything and winter is coming what
winter it's vegas by the way all
commercial break monica and sherry been
talking about the james bond movie
that's all they've been talking about
just for the record now i got to get on
board here what'd you talk about willis
[Laughter]
don't tell everybody what we actually
said john
hey this is uh this is a cool interview
renowned actor and former baseball
player thank you very much his name is
steven bishop he's known for several
different roles appearing in the rundown
with the rock yeah as david justice and
moneyball so i caught up with him about
some new things on the horizon and i
asked him about his favorite team here
in vegas
steven thank you so much for being here
i appreciate it how are things going
uh everything's going well thank you for
asking thank you for having me i really
appreciate it las vegas good morning
hello
happy monday
i want to get into this because we're
coming off the weekend everybody is
talking about james bond no time to die
whole bunch of names been thrown in
there henry cavill uh ray j john page uh
idris elba even lashawna lynch you know
the female version of james bond i'm
kind of thinking we need to throw in
stephen bishop your thoughts
well you know it's funny that uh
it's interesting a lot of people have
been asking me about this lately and
i'm hoping that it's the universe
speaking to me because not only would i
like to throw my hat into that ring
james bond when anybody asks me what's
my dream role it's james bond
it has been for you know
most of my career i mean i remember i
was on the first set first movie set i
was on a major movie set with the rock
uh the rundown yeah and i was talking to
one of the producers mark abraham and he
asked me about what's my dream job and i
told him james bond and i was back in
2003
so you know i i've been wanting to play
james bond not only i mean
i would be honored to do it i would love
to at some point be able to say
the name's bond
you got a lot going on but your love
your first love uh stephen was baseball
so you know all about the sports world
so let me throw this out there you know
vegas we just got uh the vegas golden
knights uh three years ago 2017 four
years ago we got the las vegas raiders
now who is like your favorite team right
now
obviously having the raiders there is a
huge deal um i you know i grew up in the
bay area after i left chicago i lived in
the bay area and the raiders oakland
raiders were always a mainstay there so
i'm gonna go with them uh you know
definitely good luck to mark davis and
the rest of the guys out there um that's
i think that's a perfect place for for
the raiders
i gotta wrap things up here anything
coming down the pipeline for you any new
projects
uh actually yeah we just did the third
uh of a trilogy so far of the coins
series and this one's called coins
forever uh myself in essence atkins
uh and i just wrapped an arc on uh
a show called the terminal list with
chris pratt uh for amazon prime so wow
i've got some yeah i got some things
coming all right well you're doing a
great job thank you so much for joining
me i appreciate it can't wait to see you
in vegas come on watch the raiders
thank you thank you again for having me
i really appreciate it vegas i'll see
you guys soon uh you guys be careful
take care of yourselves be good to each
other
yeah wasn't that cool he was so much fun
he was so nice to talk to and he plays a
lot of golf john and sherry and he said
the next time he's into the golf thing
because he's been busy with his schedule
he's coming to vegas i said we got some
of the best golf uh
golf playing here what am i trying to
say the courses thank you
the best golf courses here in las vegas
i totally couldn't think of it
that was good sherry hey don't forget to
catch my mlj show facebook live
weeknights at 7 pm
we got you monica we got you it's all
good thank you you got my back you got i
was thinking about this this james bond
stuff sherry's giving me her take i'm
not all excited right now
we'll sort it out 6 26 on a monday
morning thanks monica